before i met jasmine i
was looking for like a long-term
relationship
but typical dating sites
and they were not working for me
so i wanted to try something different
sugar baby
did you take girls to go on dates
a couple of times but it was dinner
dates
you just paid for dinner or you paid
them
i paid then
the couple dinner dates i went on
i kind of realized that this wasn't a
very good way for me to find true love
but clearly jasmine has the wrong
impression of me from those texts
i'm sorry i'm not a sugar baby
i ca i prefer to work to have three four
five six seven jobs
and i can accept poverty
you know
but this is depressing because men like
you
take advantage of women that need it
okay that's what you think
this is a last time you will see me in
your
life
and i thought my ex was bad
this was just an appetizer
jesus christ can you imagine like me
going to the usa
well if you can't talk peacefully then
you can you know
[Music]
uh
but this will just make me stronger
and i will find true love
because it might seem like it doesn't
but at the end
the good
the good ones
always succeed believe it or not
my time will come
so
you